Trascrizione: rosanna valente
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Le compagnie assicurative,
di fronte alle grandi calamità,
rischiano di fare bancarotta.
E allora, a loro volta si assicurano.
Le imprese che intervengono
in questi casi - le riassicurazioni -
tengono traccia di tutti questi eventi,
e ci forniscono dei dati
per noi importanti.
Ci dicono che,
nell'arco di tempo della mia vita,
gli eventi catastrofici
di origine meteoclimatica
sono più che triplicati.
Ora, non sono giovanissima:
però è comunque un grande cambiamento.
E ha radici diverse,
in parte dovuta alla crescita demografica,
in parte alla crescita economica,
che fanno sì che ci siano più persone,
e più beni esposti,
che possono subire dei danni.
E poi, c'è la crisi climatica in atto
che sta aumentando la frequenza
degli eventi pericolosi.
Ora, se da una parte è abbastanza scontato
che l'aumento delle temperature
favorisca eventi come le ondate di calore,
dall'altra parte
può risultare un po' strano
il fatto che aumentino anche eventi
tra loro antitetici:
come i nubifragi,
con le conseguenti alluvioni,
e prolungati periodi di siccità.
Con le conseguenze su raccolti,
carestie, migrazioni.
Allora, per fare luce su questo,
partiamo dal fatto
che la terra ha una coperta:
una coperta che ci protegge,
ci isola dal freddo cosmico.
È una coperta che è fatta di molecole,
i cosiddetti "gas serra"
che stanno nell'atmosfera;
e l'uomo, con molte delle sue attività,
in realtà continua ad aumentare
il numero di queste molecole
e metterne altre,
quindi la coperta
diventa sempre più spessa.
E allora, chiaramente, alla superficie,
sotto la coperta, fa più caldo.
Il cosiddetto "riscaldamento globale"
lo conosciamo tutti:
ma chiamandolo in questo modo,
non cogliamo altri fattori,
altre differenze che sono,
in realtà, molto importanti.
L'aumento della temperatura fa sì
che il 70% della superficie della Terra,
quella ricoperta dagli oceani,
si stia scaldando,
e quindi evapori maggiormente.
E questo vuol dire continuare
ad aggiungere acqua nell'atmosfera.
E non stiamo parlando
di una variazione piccola:
diciamo che, per ogni pentola d'acqua
presente nell'atmosfera negli ultimi anni,
noi abbiamo messo
un altro bel bicchierone.
Quindi parliamo
di "riscaldamento globale",
ma dovremmo anche parlare
di "annacquamento dell'aria".
E allora, penso che nessuno si stupisca
se dico che aumenta l'intensità
degli acquazzoni, dei nubifragi:
perché tutte le volte
che piove viene giù più acqua.
Per parlare della siccità, invece,
dobbiamo fare un passo ulteriore,
e capire il fatto che per avere la pioggia
non basta avere acqua nell'aria.
Ci va anche che quell'acqua
sia sotto forma liquida, come gocce,
e non sotto forma di vapore
che resta sospeso, e non lo vediamo,
come in questa stanza adesso.
Allora, l'aumento della temperatura
fa sì che l'atmosfera
possa tenere più vapore,
e quindi che l'aria faccia più fatica
a diventare pregna
e arrivare a condensare,
a formare le gocce, e poi la pioggia.
E questo è vero soprattutto
dove viviamo noi, sulla terraferma,
perché i continenti si stanno scaldando
più rapidamente del resto del globo.
Quindi; riscaldamento globale;
annacquamento dell'aria; e inaridimento.
Questo ci fa capire
che il sistema climatico
è molto complesso, molto intricato.
E allora, forse ci viene da dire:
ma come facciamo a non soccombere
agli eventi estremi?
La soluzione più ovvia è, chiaramente
togliere qualche strato
alla coperta che abbiamo messo.
E questo vuol dire ridurre
le emissioni di gas serra,
vuol dire addirittura arrivare
a emissioni negative,
cioè eliminare parte
di quello che già c'è.
E chiaramente una soluzione
che deve arrivare
dall'innovazione tecnologica,
attraverso modi che già intuiamo adesso,
già intravediamo:
ma anche altri che, assolutamente,
non riusciamo ad immaginare.
Ma io ho fiducia, perché l'inventiva
dell'uomo è notevole.
Ci credo.
Anche quella della donna, tra l'altro.
Però, in realtà, se pensiamo
alle crisi che abbiamo affrontato
la storia ci racconta
che ci sono state queste soluzioni.
Pensiamo, per esempio,
alla crisi del legname
del XVII - XVIII secolo.
In quel periodo, il legno veniva usato
sia come materiale di costruzione,
ma era anche la principale
fonte di riscaldamento.
La popolazione cresceva,
e allora aumentava, anche,
il numero di alberi tagliati.
Nel giro di pochi decenni,
si passò ad avere un prezzo
decuplicato, per il legno.
E poi,
anche tanti altri effetti collaterali
del disboscamento eccessivo
si fecero vedere,
come l'impoverimento dei suoli,
ma anche l'aumento di frane e smottamenti
laddove mancavano le radici
per tenere compatti i versanti.
È quasi un’immagine archetipica:
la terra che si sgretola, che si disfa
per effetto dell’azione dell’uomo.
E poi cosa successe?
La Rivoluzione Industriale,
l'invenzione della macchina a vapore
che permise di estrarre carbone
dove prima era difficile farlo:
e quindi, nel giro di un breve periodo
la richiesta di legno diminuì.
Problema risolto.
Poi, ovviamente, ne arrivarono altri,
ma quel problema [fu] risolto.
Ora, non sto dicendo
che dobbiamo stare fermi, non fare nulla
e aspettare che arrivi
un mitologico inventore geniale
a portarci la soluzione,
perché la Storia ci dice, anche,
che ci sono crisi
che non sono state risolte.
E per rimanere nel tema del legno,
pensiamo alla crisi della civiltà
dell'Isola di Pasqua.
La leggenda narra, in quel caso,
che gli abitanti arrivarono a tagliare
l'ultimo albero d'alto fusto,
senza rendersi conto
che non avrebbero più avuto il materiale
per costruire le imbarcazioni
di cui avevano fondamentale bisogno
per procacciarsi ciò che era
di assoluta necessità per loro.
Quindi, problema che non è
stato risolto, in quel caso.
Magari non è esattamente andata così,
qualche storico dice
sia andata in modo diverso:
Ma non importa, a noi questa storiella
serve, semplicemente,
per ricordarci che le azioni
hanno delle conseguenze.
E quindi, magari, ricordiamocene
anche quando scegliamo
i nostri governanti,
i nostri amministratori,
perché le scelte che loro fanno
sono poi le vie
sulle quali camminiamo noi,
cammineranno i nostri figli,
i nostri nipoti.
Perché è necessario creare le condizioni
affinché ci sia
questo sviluppo tecnologico.
È necessario favorire
lo sviluppo delle idee
attraverso l'educazione,
attraverso la ricerca, l'innovazione.
Quindi, sviluppo tecnologico da una parte.
Ma non basta, però:
non basta perché la crisi climatica
è solo uno dei problemi che abbiamo.
Se pensiamo a inquinamento,
perdita di biodiversità,
non sostenibilità
del nostro stile di vita,
questi sono altre sfaccettature,
altre espressioni dello stesso problema
che ha radici molto profonde,
e che è legato al nostro modo
di relazionarci col mondo.
Se si risolvessero il problema
del cambiamento climatico -
cioè il problema dei gas serra -
senza affrontare queste altre questioni,
perderemmo un’occasione immensa
di fare davvero una rivoluzione,
di cambiare le cose per il meglio.
Parlavo di radici profonde
perché tutto parte, in realtà,
da quando l'uomo ha cominciato
a controllare la natura,
ha imparato ad accendere il fuoco
e quindi a poter cuocere gli alimenti,
e fondere i metalli,
senza aver bisogno di aspettare i fulmini.
Ha imparato a controllare l'acqua,
per irrigare i campi
senza aspettare la pioggia.
Ha imparato a conservare i cibi,
per permettergli di sopravvivere
durante l'inverno sterile, freddo,
senza aver bisogno di migrare.
In breve, ha imparato a controllare
e a slegarsi dai ritmi della natura.
E adesso noi apriamo il rubinetto,
pigiamo l'interruttore della luce,
regoliamo il termostato;
e viviamo in condizioni
estremamente stabili.
Tutto questo ha portato
un incredibile miglioramento
del nostro stile di vita:
ci ha permesso di nutrire
popolazioni immense.
È una storia di grande successo,
la storia della nostra civiltà.
Però attenzione,
perché ci ha anche slegati dal tempo,
ci ha slegati dalle
condizioni meteorologiche
che scandiscono lo scorrere
di passato, presente e futuro.
Ci ha slegati da questi
tempi della natura,
ci ha fatto anche illudere del fatto
che le risorse siano illimitate.
Oggi davvero, talvolta,
pensiamo che l'unico limite
alle cose che possiamo avere
sia il denaro che possediamo
per comprarle.
Infatti, l'umanità è arrivata
a consumare in un anno
quello che il pianeta ci può dare
in più di un anno e mezzo.
Siamo arrivati a pensare
di aver domato il mondo,
di averlo piegato al nostro volere;
e adesso, ci raccontiamo
che la soluzione ai problemi che abbiamo
sia un ulteriore addomesticamento,
un maggiore controllo
per allontanare da noi
quella paura del clima che cambia.
Ma in realtà,
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno
è di avere più rispetto, per il pianeta.
E allora, pensiamo a quanto
ci viene facile, naturale
provare rispetto per ciò che amiamo.
E che amiamo ciò che conosciamo;
e lo sconosciuto, l'ignoto,
invece, ci fa paura.
Allora, mai come adesso
conosciamo il pianeta:
perché lo osserviamo, lo monitoriamo,
lo misuriamo con 1000 sensori,
sappiamo, possiamo conoscere esattamente
qual è l'umidità del suolo
e decidere con precisione
quanto irrigare quella piantina,
quanti nutrimenti dare.
Ma lo facciamo tutto con sensori
che non sono in grado di attivare
le nostre emozioni.
Allora, la strada che io propongo
è proprio quella del sentimento,
anche - anzi, soprattutto -
nel suo senso etimologico
di "percepire attraverso i sensi".
Sentire l'odore di un bosco
al mattino presto;
correre sotto la pioggia;
scottarci le dita
mentre accendiamo un fuoco;
avere la pelle d'oca per un vento gelido;
osservare le api volare
sulle fioriture primaverili
di questi giorni - siamo a novembre...
E tutto questo provocherà
sentimento vero, meraviglia, conoscenza.
Il rispetto sarà una conseguenza naturale
di questo diverso modo di relazionarci.
E non ci saremo arrivati
scappando dal terrore delle catastrofi.
Sappiamo che non funzionano
le scritte sui pacchetti di sigarette:
"Fumare fa male".
Ci saremmo arrivati mossi da un'attrazione
verso una relazione armoniosa ed armonica.
Pura meraviglia.
(Applausi)